the true identities of the five Elders
the true backstory of imusama the Holy
Night father of Shanks and more will be
revealed in this epic chapter of one
piece so make sure to stay tuned for
that Oda is going for a month-long break
after this so you know he always goes
out with a bang before breaks let alone
one this long chill the parking with it
and smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming make this the video
you joined to knock on by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn all notifications on so you don't
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all we get a pretty
epic cover this week showing off Luffy
Kobe but also GARP looking Fierce I love
to see Luffy and GARP looking like
they're fighting together on the same
side like that and hopefully we see that
as time goes on and the truth of how
corrupt the world government actually is
comes to garb's attention I know he
knows some of it but I feel like when he
knows all of it he should side with
Luffy like it makes sense so this could
be foreshadowing we also get a cool
color spread but are noticeably missing
Zorro we're told no rain no rainbow a
pretty cool message when you think about
it this chapter is called the five Elder
planets and of course it's emphasizing
the fact that as mentioned we are about
to learn Vital Information about the
five Elders which is all the more
relevant now that one is coming to
Egghead with kizaru we're told the
curtains close on the reverie before the
news of King Cobra's murder came to
light we see Vivi being looked for Cobra
being looked for and man it's really not
looking good for alabasta then we're
told a number of stowaways hold their
breath as they attempt to escape on
various Royal vessels we see Vivi with
waffle on the Aegis kingdoms ship and we
see how Morgan's agrees to pretend to
look for a scoop from them so that these
two have a chance to hop aboard his
vessel Morgans for his part thinks that
a king becoming the subject of a Manhunt
is big news which is of course what big
news Morgans is interested in he says he
can't wait to hear all about it Libby
for her part wants to know what wapul
saw while wah pool just tells her to go
back to her own ship only to be told she
can't because of cp0 they are no joke
and even if people tried to help her it
won't be enough against such a threat
Vivi then wants to reach out to her dad
but wapo is like anything but that and
tells her to get lost already this will
definitely be a comedic Duo moving
forward even last chapter they were
hilarious we then see that Bibby and
Sabo are being looked for we see a cute
bunny thinking she's hungry she's a
stowaway on the Tajin Kingdom's ship and
Sabo is laying bloody in the LA Lucia
Kingdom ship he thinks to himself if he
can just make it there he knows he can
figure out something still of course he
has no idea he will be framed for
Cobra's death he's just thinking about
how Cobra entrusted him with the
important information and told him he
must live on then we're told these two
key stories spread across the globe the
murder of King Cobra and The
Disappearance of bivvy and again I gotta
say not a good reverie for the alabasta
kingdom we then jump to the five Elders
discussing stuff as usual they comment
that Sabo seems to have a checkered fate
and that he's constantly being
surrounded by those who bear the letter
D they wanted to deal with Egghead now
but now it seems this Sabo stuff will
have to take priority then emu calls and
they're like yo what's up great emu emu
is still chilling in the flower room as
usual emu says the time has come to put
vegapunk's invention to the test use the
mother flame which by the way crazy name
I like it and again to me it kind of
implies that emu Sama will turn out to
be female but we'll see they discuss how
yeah they couldn't try it yet so they
couldn't ascertain its Effectiveness
they even say depending on how well the
experiment goes Egghead May reconsider
its response as they wonder what the
target emu says lulucia Kingdom and we
know how it will be erased but the
Assumption was that it was a race
because Saba was there and they helped
Sabo or at least the government thought
Sabo was there however this was not
actually the case at all as we're about
to learn here we see how emu thinks it's
pointed out that a lot of people lived
there but emu just says that is of no
consequence it's almost like imusama is
saying why are you even telling me such
irrelevant information for emu that is
no different than firing a shot into the
sea the point is to test for
Effectiveness no one goes against emu as
they say that the world moves at the
will of the Creator which appears to be
emu here One Elder simply wonders why La
Lucia and emu says it's close proximity
is the reason we then get all the names
and titles of the five Elders so they're
introduced as the five Elder planets
defense science Warrior God Saint J
Garcia Saturn environmental Warrior God
Saint Marcus Mars Justice Warrior God
Topman Valkyrie Finance Warrior God
Ethan Baron V nusruro and agriculture
Warrior God Shepherd Jew Peter so they
are all described as Warrior Gods which
is hype and as we know they appear to
have devil fruit Powers as we saw last
chapter 2 so these guys are definitely
forced to be reckoned with in their own
right I can't wait to see when I
actually go all out just as imusama
seems to be immortal as mentioned later
in this chapter these five might be as
well otherwise they do seem to be older
than you'd expect Warrior Gods to be
eventually the elders justify emu's
decision about the Lucius saying their
citizens have shown Sparks of rebellion
recently we may have to make an example
of them they also think about it like
it's an atomic bomb which I think is an
important comparison as we'll see later
anyways they say if they could use this
freely they could instantly snuff out
any protracted conflict and there's
definitely apt commentary here on
governments they first decide what place
to Target for their own benefit and
after the fact create a narrative that
justifies their actions emu also makes
it clear that the retrieval of Vivi is a
priority which isn't really surprising
since we saw emu holding that picture of
Vivi before of course that's going to
come into play Then fast forward to the
Marines and they're speaking of how the
kingdom of Tajin and Aegis in other
words the ships that Bonnie and Vivian
WAP pool escaped with are both rebelling
between the disbanding of the seven
Warlords we're told and the uprisings in
government Affiliated Nations the Navy
has their hands full however their
military power had already gone in a New
Direction and then we see them deploying
the seraphim because crocodile was
spotted on empty Bluffs Island and by
the way that name is so hilarious gotta
say it we notably see seraphim versions
of doflamingo Moria and crocodile I
think what they really need is to reveal
their secret weapon though the buggy
seraphim AKA s clown but seriously it'll
be interesting to see how far they went
because a Blackbeard seraphim and lost
seraphim would be pretty overpowered and
they were also Warlords at some point
then we jump back to sabo's Hype
conversation with the revolutionaries
specifically with dragon and ivankov you
know that conversation that's so insane
that anyone who hears it could die he
says the second they docked Lucia the
people arrested King seki and and
Princess comma name they were waiting to
Ambush the Royals since Saba was a
stowaway he was welcomed with open arms
that's when he saw the papers and found
out he was framed for Cobra's murder the
people considered him a hero and Sabo
kept his mouth shut because he saw how
that lie fanned the Flames a rebellion
within them he ended up bringing many of
those hopeful revolutionary recruits
back with him he didn't have an
encryption snail so he rerouted his call
through La Lucia he knew the government
would intercept the signal but doing it
this way would make it seem like he's
still in La Lucia even if he was already
in the sea and it's revealed that the
annihilation of the Lucia really did
happen during that call the people on
board were hysterical since a lot of
them still had family on the island I'm
sure that made them even more motivated
as revolutionaries seeing what the
government is capable of doing to their
loved ones Dragon wonders how they did
it how did they cause so much damage
Sabo points out that it was an enormous
shadow that appeared above the clouds he
says something pitch black was flying
above and it wasn't a living thing or
natural disaster faster ivankov then
brings it back to EMU saying one of the
first 20 subaranes 800 years ago was
Saint emu of house narona then pointing
to a book ivankov says we know an
ability granting Eternal youth is said
to exist so this emu person probably has
the same thing and doesn't need to worry
about death Sabo asks if they think this
emu he saw was the same one from back
then ivankov admits it could be a
coincidence but at the same time doubts
that anyone else but a Founder could
command the five Elder planets the
highest of world Nobles he says the
dragons fancy themselves the descendants
of the Gods after all and so that could
be how they view emu as a god which goes
with the fact that the elders recently
referred to EMU as the Creator so a lot
of the pieces of the puzzle seem to be
coming together here ivankov then
predicts that the weapon used was
created by vegapunk Dragon insists that
vegapunk would never intentionally
design a dedicated killing machine and
that's true of the vegapunk we know but
I mentioned how Vega Punk looked like
Einstein before and Einstein's findings
were used to create the atomic bomb
without his consent so that's probably
what happened here too if I had to bet
on it they briefly bring up the
possibility of an ancient weapon but
Dragon thinks that they would have used
it before if they had it we then jump to
present day where a Celestial Dragon has
been sentenced to death but this
information will never be reported to
the world we're told which makes sense
they want Celestial dragons to always
come off as Untouchable we see that in
marijua people are complaining that
their food supply is gone they have no
bread all they have is cake this
definitely reminds me of that one quote
said to be spoken by a great princess
upon being told her peasants have no
bread she said let them eat cake it
represents how detached from reality the
privilege can be and that's definitely
how the celestial dragons are portrayed
as well so it's a fitting reference and
a pretty funny one anyways we are now
getting to the craziest most insane most
high part of the chapter we see a figure
whose hair and beard make the shape of a
crescent moon since Luffy our
protagonist is represented as a sun god
associated with the sun it's feeling
that this enemy is associated with the
moon we're told that the judge for the
Celestial Dragon was the former King of
the land known as wait for it God Valley
yes where Roger and GARP fought rocks
the zebek and a one-year-old Shanks was
found but wait it gets even better we're
told he currently serves as the supreme
commander of God's night his name is
Saint Garling figarland and the
figarland family was associated with
Shanks in the one-piece red movie
heavily suggesting that this could very
well be shanks's father the man he
executed was Saint Don Quixote miosgard
for defending the Fishman he says anyone
who protects scum is lower than the scum
they protect the narrator Hypes him up
further by saying this is a man who can
even judge the celestial dragons so
there you have it one way or another
this dude is definitely related to
Shanks so let me know immediately your
thoughts and predictions about it in the
comments and if you find Shanks as hype
as me right now then you don't want to
miss my hour-long video about Shanks
explaining everything you need to know
so far about this epic but mysterious
character link on screen to that right
now and I'll see you there